[Music]
on this thursday night ukrainians
holding back russian ground forces
but russia keeps up the unrelenting
aerial bombardment the cities under
siege
honoring the ukrainian soldiers making
the ultimate sacrifice
and canada's prime minister in poland
offering more support to ukrainian
refugees plus the west's economic weapon
how sanctions are isolating russia and
tanking its economy
and potential astronomical repercussions
how war on earth is threatening peace in
space
[Music]
global national with donna friesen
[Music]
as this war enters its third week kiev
has been transformed into a capital city
of a country at war
the mayor says almost 2 million of its 3
million residents have now fled many of
those still there are prepared to fight
russian soldiers who aren't far away
the ukrainian army outmanned and
outgunned is managing to hold back
russian ground troops from taking kiev
in what is an existential battle against
a neighbor whose leader says their
country doesn't have the right to exist
good evening and thanks for joining us
outside key of the russian bombardment
has not stopped residential areas are
under siege including in ukraine's
second largest city harkief
he didn't go according to putin's plan
and that is why now he continues
bombarding our cities killing civilians
dropping bombs on residential areas our
military is doing an incredible job here
on the ground
continuing to push back russian troops
away from kharkiv and we will win i'm
sure that we will win
the first high-level peace talks of this
war took place today but ended without
resolution in the u.s pentagon officials
say russian ground forces have now moved
five kilometers closer to kiev city
center and weapons deliveries from the
west to the ukrainian military are still
getting through our coverage begins with
crystal gomencing and a warning some of
the images in her story are disturbing
ukrainian precision strikes against
russian tanks amassing near kiev an
operation to keep the invading forces
out of the capital
tactical maneuvers in an ongoing and
brutal war
russian forces continue to bear down on
mariupol a new giant scar inflicted on
the city full of people on the edge
we are being bombarded from all
directions pray for the mothers with
children please it is very hard here
a child and two adults were killed
following an attack on a maternity and
children's hospital wednesday an attack
the president of ukraine and other world
leaders are calling a war crime
i only want this to be finished says
this social services worker he has the
horrific task of moving bodies to a mass
grave a trench running roughly 25 meters
was dug near a cemetery in the port city
earlier this week there is no time for
funerals or to mourn
attention and efforts are focused on
keeping people alive
[Music]
soldiers ngos and volunteers work to get
ukrainians to safety 2.3 million have
escaped the violence so far according to
the united nations but these journeys
are fraught with danger
from the international humanitarian law
point of view humanitarian corridors
need to be taken
with absolute security
not just evacuating people who want to
leave the cities that are under attack
but also to be able to provide
food
non-food items water to those who are
willing to stay in those cities as the
onslaught of attacks continue those
wanting to stay are running out of
options
and hope
crystal gomanson global news london
some of ukraine's fallen soldiers are
being laid to rest it's not clear how
many have been killed it's estimated to
be between two to four thousand russian
losses are impossible to verify it's
thought as many as six thousand have
died there's a church in la vie that has
a relationship with the ukrainian
military going back three centuries
hundreds of people have been gathering
there this week to honor the sacrifice
of soldiers our mike armstrong was
invited to attend
[Music]
it has been a very busy week at this
church there was a funeral held
wednesday at levi's garrison church of
the holy apostles peter and paul it was
a service for three fallen soldiers a
day before there was a funeral for two
and a day before that three more
[Music]
father nestor kazeek admits being a
military chaplain at a time of war is
hard psychologically burying so many
young men or as he calls them boys
their lives that should have had many
years left this week they've had
soldiers who've just started families
some who were just married and one who
didn't quite make it that far
father kazek says one of the soldiers
had just proposed to his girlfriend and
then went to fight
now this church has a relationship with
the military that goes back three
centuries off to the side of this church
there are posters that the faces of
soldiers lost in a war that people here
will tell you didn't start two weeks ago
it began with the occupation of crimea
they've been adding posters here since
2014.
now they also have these boards this is
a war that's still being fought and
they're adding photographs of fallen
soldiers individually as they're killed
all this by the way and they still
haven't had the chance to put up the
soldiers remembered in this week's
funerals
a 28 year old senior lieutenant his
fiancee and his close family attended
the military funeral in la vie but there
was another
grew up in a village about an hour
outside the city that entire village
came out to pay their respects
this man says vushavani was a patriot
his loss the sacrifice of a brave young
man
now in just two weeks the two sides in
this conflict have lost thousands of
soldiers those are statistics if you
don't have a name
everyone here on this day new
at least one
mike armstrong global news la viv
ukraine
[Music]
ukraine's president has agreed to speak
to canada's parliament on march 15th
this war is being fought in ukraine but
it's echoing all over the world most of
the two million refugees who have fled
have gone to poland that's where prime
minister justin trudeau is today abigail
beeman is traveling with the prime
minister
and we are all standing with you justin
trudeau meets ukrainian refugees forced
to flee who crossed poland's border and
are now in warsaw
acting as translator his deputy prime
minister go home go home russia go home
one heartbreaking story after another in
a country that sees up to 100 000 new
refugees a day we live in kharkiv for
all our life it's my home
i really love my city it's really
beautiful but now uh the
center
was boom bombing
yeah yeah he was bombed
and every beautiful places
are ruined and it's so sad
poland has opened its arms wide at the
warsaw central train station there's
free food clothes accommodations because
these are our neighbors
and we have to help them the polish
president has heard as many as 5 million
people could reach his country he's
worried in just a few days the crisis
will be too big to handle but canada was
one of the first to offer support your
prime minister was the only uh the only
leader in the world who called me
andrei
if you mean
we will help you when was that call like
what day was that on
two days before
thursday trudeau announced 117 million
more dollars to help implement the
fast-tracked immigration plans canada
has promised but there are criticisms
it's not happening fast enough canada
will help canada is there to help and
it's not just a challenge for canada we
find ourselves
by coincidence or maybe fate
to be here in wausau at the same time
trudeau met with u.s vice president
kamala harris for an hour thursday where
once again ukraine and russia topped the
agenda this was his final bilateral
meeting before he heads back to canada
friday abigail beeman global news warsaw
seven of russia's wealthiest and most
influential oligarchs have had their
assets frozen by the uk government
including billionaire roman abramovich
owner of the chelsea football club the
sanctions mean his plan to sell the team
is on hold the government did give it a
special license to keep operating but it
can't sell new tickets to future matches
the uk says abramovich has had a close
relationship with vladimir putin for
decades and benefited financially from
it abramovic denies that
there are reports tonight power has been
restored to the chernobyl nuclear
facility in ukraine russia's energy
minister says belarusian specialists
have reconnected the electricity the
international atomic energy agency
though can't confirm that because it
says ukraine has lost contact with the
facility chernobyl is being held by
russian forces
the foreign ministers of ukraine and
russia held their first face-to-face
talks today since russia started the war
russia continues to demand ukraine
surrender and as jackson prescott
reports any faint hope of a ceasefire
quickly evaporated
if ukrainians were hopeful russia might
soften its demands a 90-minute summit
made it clear that won't happen
we cannot stop the war if the country
which committed the aggression the
invasion does not have a desire to do so
said ukraine's foreign minister after
the meeting
two weeks in there's no movement toward
a cease-fire
and no progress on establishing
humanitarian corridors to help the
beleaguered citizens of ukraine escape
negotiation may be impossible because
russia's claims are so detached from
reality
we didn't attack ukraine proclaimed
russian foreign minister sergey lavrov a
situation threatening directly the
russian federation security was there he
said
lavrov dismissed concerns about civilian
casualties as pathetic outcries
he even suggested the russian bombing of
a maternity hospital was justified
claiming the building was occupied by
ukrainian radicals not women or doctors
on social media russian diplomats
falsely claimed these pregnant women
seen in the rubble were actually actors
russian forces are at the very least
operating with reckless disregard for
the safety of civilians as russian units
launch artillery and airstrikes into
urban areas
the defiance stretches all the way to
the kremlin where vladimir putin told
his cabinet a newly isolated russia
would emerge stronger than ever
ukraine's fierce resistance may still
upend those plans
the door remains open to a diplomatic
end to the war but ukraine is clear
surrender will never be an option
jackson proskow global news washington
the exodus of people from ukraine
continues a u.n refugee agency estimates
more than 2.3 million people have fled
well over half of them are in poland
other neighboring countries including
moldova are also taking in people
mercedes stephenson is there
fleeing a war zone with her young son
boris and her 78 year old
wheelchair-bound mother janna has been a
nightmare for olga voro
just horrible that's why we're on the
way
the russian military bombed her
neighbor's house and despite the
challenges of evacuating olga realized
civilians were being targeted
deliberately and she had to get out to
survive
they started to bomb just normal houses
of people
not really anything else their difficult
journey led them to moldova where
refugees are welcomed well they're our
neighbors
the generosity of this small and
relatively poor country is unmistakable
moldovans have opened their hearts and
their homes to those fleeing the war
look it's really heartbreaking some like
anatole malenka have traded their jobs
to volunteer working around the clock to
feed transport and house tens of
thousands of people
well look we saw a need we actually
heard bombings
we realized it's happening on the other
side so we decided at least as much as
we can as long as we are safe we want to
at least do something good so this day
care is now where local women are
cooking for the masses in an effort that
far outscales their resources
there is a fear among volunteers we
spoke to they could run out of food as
more people arrive
donation centers in the capital are
overflowing with support but handing the
supplies out is a challenge with
refugees scattered across many camps and
private homes the issue is trying to get
the district to get it distributed
properly get it in the hands of the
people that need it for some the support
is appreciated but the strain is too
much
we found 18-year-old mom violetta
heading back into ukraine with her 11
month old baby eva
she knows the risks of going back she
says but she cannot bear to be without
her husband
and would rather be together as a family
whatever comes
the number of refugees here in the
capital of kishana has reduced in recent
days because they are now being moved to
other parts of europe but there is fear
that that could pick up substantially in
coming days if there is an attack on
odessa those numbers could spike to as
many as one million refugees crossing
the border into moldova donna mercedes
thanks
another province is relaxing its public
health restrictions coming up the
changes coming to bc and when they'll
take effect
[Music]
british columbia is dropping many of its
coveted public health measures as of
midnight face masks will no longer be
required in indoor public spaces
residents in care homes will be able to
have more visitors and there will be no
more capacity limits for faith
gatherings and bc's proof of vaccination
requirement will end on april
public health measures are also starting
to ease for the house of commons the
mass mandate will remain through june
the end of the spring sitting the
viewing gallery in the house of commons
will reopen to the public on april 25th
for the first time since the pandemic
began and guided tours in general public
access to the west block will also
resume in mid-may
in gander newfoundland a canadian forces
helicopter has crashed the air force
says the cormorant helicopter was
conducting hovering maneuvers at the
gander airport prior to the accident in
a tweet the air force says six air crew
were on board two were in hospital
receiving treatment four have been
released and are back with their
squadron
from russia without love ahead how
russia's economy is being crushed
[Music]
western sanctions are having a
devastating impact on russia's economy
the currency the ruble has lost about 50
percent of its value since vladimir
putin invaded ukraine two weeks ago and
now takes about 120 russian rubles to
buy one u.s dollar russia's credit
rating has been downgraded to the second
lowest level possible by fitch ratings
which warns the country is on the brink
of defaulting on its debts
hundreds of foreign companies have
halted doing business in russia
including goldman sachs the first major
american bank to say it's pulling out of
the country and as eric sorenson reports
the russian people aren't getting the
full picture about why this is happening
the utter destruction of ukraine is not
being seen by the people whose country
is causing it state television where
most russians get their information
presents vladimir putin's message a
military operation welcomed by
ukrainians and sanitized for russian
consumption
many russians don't want to know as
radio free europe discovered
i support putin says this woman i won't
look at these photos
this man insists no one is bombing keeve
i don't believe it
and those who do believe it and speak
out are quickly rounded up and jailed
but no amount of propaganda or
censorship can shield everyday russians
from the global backlash
starting with long lineups for cash and
now seeing major companies pulling up
stakes some 300 businesses led by the
tech industry and payment systems are
pausing operations in russia from fast
food and fossil fuels to cars computers
and parkas one moscow resident who does
not want to be identified tells global
news it is depressing i think people are
starting to feel it fast food chains or
like closed brands are living in the
country which affects
citizens affects their own lives even
though they don't feel like they should
participate in it the closing of more
than 800 mcdonald's marks the end of an
opening to russia that was hoped would
democratize russia and it is the russian
people who will feel the isolation and
unemployment brought about by vladimir
putin's invasion
he is sealing his country off completely
from the rest of the world because no
one in in the media right now because
it's controlled the russian government
will tell that truth to the russian
people one teacher willing to talk
publicly tells global news an increasing
number of russians do not believe the
propaganda and must speak out the least
we can do is just to to show the rest of
the world that well actually uh the
russians are not very
supportive of that war the question is
whether russian's own suffering and
setbacks will make president putin
change course or cause him to escalate
the russian attack on ukraine eric
sorensen global news toronto
next how the war in ukraine is
threatening peace and stability in space
as russia's president continues on the
path of war it risks straining relations
in space the international space station
is multinational and collaborative 15
countries including the us russia and
canada work together to run it and it's
always risen above any geopolitical
crises now as heather urex west explains
that is being tested
looking down from the international
space station divisions on earth seem
insignificant and small
russia has worked collaboratively with
the west on the iss since the end of the
cold war it's a partnership that has
withstood geopolitical tensions before
the station had a wall built around it
that kept it isolated from tensions on
earth
and
that wall seems to be crumbling a little
bit with the inflammatory character of
mr rogozon's comments dimitri rogazan is
the head of the russian space agency he
recently posted a video of partner
country's national flags being removed
from a russian rocket to which former
u.s astronaut scott kelly responded in
russian without those flags in the
foreign exchange they bring in your
space program won't be worth a damn
right now the seven-person crew at the
iss is made up of two russians four
americans and one german but later this
month three more russian cosmonauts are
scheduled to arrive at the iss while an
american and two russians are slated to
come home so seeing how that works if
they all get get back to earth on board
the same rocket ship or not will really
determine um i feel like the fate of the
iss when it comes to this collaboration
but there are already signs that russia
is pulling back the russian space agency
announced over twitter that the state
corporation will not cooperate with
germany on joint experiments on the
russian segment of the iss adding the
russian space program will be adjusted
against the backdrop of sanctions with
the priority becoming the creation of
satellites in the interest of defense
those divisions appear now to be
escaping from the confines of earth
heather ux west global news calgary
and that is global national for this
thursday i'm donna friesen we leave you
tonight with a call for peace
this is budapest hungary a candlelight
vigil in support of the people of
ukraine
if their message wasn't clear enough
from the ground
take a look at it from above
thanks for watching hope to see you here
again tomorrow
bye-bye
again